Sam bakemanfried was finally arrested
yesterday putting him on the coffee
Zilla Wall of Shame and today we have
huge Bombshells to share with you of all
the new evidence that just came out
starting with his arrest the Royal
Bahamas police force just arrested Sam
last night in cooperation with the
United States in light of criminal
charges finally being filed against Sam
he's been accused of multiple counts of
Fraud and we're going to talk about
everything he's accused of but first I
want to say I know we haven't heard
anything from law enforcement up to this
point but clearly it's not because they
weren't working they just didn't want to
scare Sam into fleeing the country in
fact the Department of Justice hid their
indictment from the public they sealed
it in order to prevent Sam from knowing
they were coming and that strategy seems
to have worked because even days before
his arrest Sam was publicly saying in
interviews that he didn't think he would
be arrested you're certain that once all
the investigations have happened that
you won't be arrested for fraud I don't
think I will be I don't think that I I
don't think I tried to do anything wrong
wow so it looks like he fell for it Sam
must have thought that he was gonna get
away with it but that is not the case
and now that he is arrested law
enforcement have now all come out of the
woodwork all at once publicizing their
work so several charges got levied
against Sam from different law
enforcement organizations and we're
going to go through all of them
including new evidence that we did not
know before but first I wanted a little
more context so I asked a great YouTube
lawyer legal eagle to kind of break down
this situation for us to explain who's
going after Sam why and what we can
expect in terms of punishment yeah there
was a time when it was an open question
as to whether the US government would
actually prosecute Sam bankman freed and
which department of the government had
jurisdiction and there were three likely
candidates the cftc the SEC and the doj
those questions have now been answered
and the answer is everyone putting
together a successful prosecution for
white-collar crimes takes a lot of time
and while critics said that SPF would
never be prosecuted getting two
complaints in one indictment this pass
is about as fast as the government can
do absolutely anything now the cftc and
the SEC filed civil complaints seeking
monetary damages and injunctive relief
to prevent SPF from being basically near
a corporation or anyone's money ever
again the doj filed a criminal
indictment related to wire fraud charges
conspiracy money laundering and campaign
finance charges now unlike the cftc and
the SEC complaints if the doj convicts
SPF could be looking at some serious
jail time it's hard to say exactly how
much because at this point we don't have
all the facts related to the crime
seriousness scores or the potential
sentencing enhancements but here there
are three groups of victims FTX
customers Alameda lenders and the United
States more victims generally means
consecutive rather than concurrent
sentences and the more money at issue
the more severe the sentence for some
offenses any crime involving more than
550 million dollars gets the max
enhancements so we could easily be
talking about more than 20 years in jail
wow that's very helpful context thanks
to legal eagle for that Insight he'll be
linked in the description below but now
that we know what's going on I want to
start talking about the sec's complaint
because today they accused Sam of
defrauding investors for 1.8 billion
dollars quote bankman freed was
orchestrating a massive years-long fraud
diverting billions of dollars of
customer funds for his own personal
benefit now these are accusations we're
familiar with but there's very
interesting information here about
alameda's missing eight billion dollars
if you remember during one of my
interviews with Sam we asked him where
all the money had gone and he told us
that there was this accounting error
which caused him to forget about eight
billion dollars of customer funds that
had been put in a poorly labeled Fiat
account and had been lent and lost by
Alameda research but the SEC in this
complaint says that wasn't an accident
it was held in an account called Fiat
ftx.com which wasn't poorly labeled for
no reason or because it was a mistake
according to the SEC Sam directed
Alameda to hide this because he was
quote concerned that this enormous
liability would alarm alameda's lenders
and that kind of makes sense if you know
somebody doesn't have a billion dollars
owes eight billion dollars that is
pretty alarming and would make you think
twice and this could be huge evidence of
intentional fraud and not only that the
SEC claims on multiple occasions bankman
freed directed FTX to increase the
credit line amount by which Alameda
could maintain a negative balance on
their platform to the point where it
grew to billions of dollars and
effectively became Limitless now again
we are familiar with that claim but
here's another thing we didn't know
because apparently Sam Bateman freed
also directed their 8 billion dollar
liability to be moved into an account
that wouldn't be charged interest like
any normal user so in other words he
purposely moved their margin account
which he said he didn't know about he
said he didn't know about this 8 billion
into an account that wouldn't be charged
interest like most of ftx's users so all
of this evidence makes it seemingly
impossible that he didn't know about
this stub account or Fiat account
whatever he wants to call it like he
claims clearly he knew and the SEC
accusing him of this adds a lot of
credibility to that now in addition to
the SEC this internal knowledge of Sam
and Alameda was further confirmed in a
hearing today in the U.S House committee
where the bankruptcy lawyer John Ray III
who's overseeing the FTX bankruptcy he
was asked about if there's any way Sam
didn't know about the back door access
that Alameda had and here's what he said
that back door which you've said allowed
for unlimited access of Alameda
essentially unlimited access into the
FTX customer accounts to fund their
Investments
in your eyes is there any way that
Sam bankman freed or Senior Management
wouldn't know about this sort of thing
no wow Sam is getting slammed from every
direction including the guy overseeing
his company's own bankruptcy you know
what I couldn't be happier because up
till now it's just been Sam talking
about how this was an embarrassing
mistake and finally the adults have come
in the room we have real investigators
forensic professionals saying there's no
shot that this story is true on top of
that the company's own accounting
practices were just horrific which I
found funny they used QuickBooks
multi-billion dollar company using
QuickBooks QuickBooks QuickBooks I like
how the congresswoman can't even believe
it could be so terrible at FTX I mean I
know this isn't evidence of fraud it's
just kind of funny and embarrassing
because I use QuickBooks for my YouTube
channel but these guys are using it for
a billion dollar organization and you
can tell this bankruptcy lawyer is like
oh my gosh they're using QuickBooks
nothing against QuickBooks very nice
tool just not for a multi-billion dollar
company
now from here I want to move on from the
SEC and the house committee and I want
to talk about the cftc revelations
because they also filed a complaint and
again it's really bad for Sam it's a 40
page document but most alarming is this
Revelation according to the cftc Sam
Bateman freed knew back in September
remember they went bankrupt in November
he knew back in September that Alameda
was hopelessly insolvent and he
considered shutting it down quote in or
around September 2022 bankman free
drafted and shared a document that
questioned whether Alameda should be
permanently shut down the document
titled we came we saw we researched
began I only started thinking about this
today and so haven't vetted it much but
I think it might be time for Alameda
research to shut down honestly it was
probably time to do that a year ago and
then he says the most alarming part
quote the fact we didn't hedge as much
as we should have alone cost more in
expected value than all the money
Alameda has ever made or ever will make
in other words they were down bad they
had lost more money than they ever made
or ever will make he knew they weren't
coming back from this back in September
but did he unwind it did he release this
document no he kept the scam going and
it's just further evidence of this being
an intentional fraud now from here we're
finally going to move to the Big Kahuna
the Department of Justice complaint
where we get to the criminal allegations
and we talk about jail time so today the
doj released the sealed indictment where
they revealed eight counts of fraud now
we're not going to go through every
single one of them because they kind of
repeat but they range from like
conspiracy to commit wire fraud and wire
fraud itself to conspiracy to money
launder and then also conspiracy to
violate campaign Finance laws going back
to the huge donations to political
parties they made but the big takeaway
is that if he actually goes down for
these eight things he's facing serious
prison time and in my opinion I think
he's going to be declared guilty of at
least some of these I think the evidence
is overwhelming I personally have a
confession from Sam that he co-mingled
funds we've got SEC complaints that he
knowingly hid those eight billion
dollars we got the cftc saying he knew
back in September that Alameda was in
trouble so it's just there's too much
stacked against him is what I'm saying
but ultimately we will see what happens
and you don't actually know until the
actual trial happens so we will be
following it closely but either way I
just wanted to say this is a Win
Regardless the fact that he's arrested
the fact he's going to have to stand
trial and answer for what he's done and
not be able to weasel his way out of it
is something I'm very happy about it's a
huge win for everyone I just wanted to
cover this real quick thank you for
watching thank you for supporting and I
will see you in the next one